On election night when Donald Trump came out in the early hours of the morning
and said, um, I believe we've already won.
We've won. As far as I'm concerned. He said, I gasped I gas. I thought,
Oh, how? And there's several things about that.
One is you better. If you're the Trump team,
you better provide really good fast about that. And frankly,
what they've provided is not good enough proof yet they have
been providing, uh,
some things that sound to me like they are conspiracy theories,
unless they've got a lot of stuff to come. I hope for their sake.
They've got a lot of stuff to come,
or there are a lot of reputations that are being trashed all the time.
More than eight out of 10 Trump voters in the last poll I saw
believe Donald Trump won the election.
And obviously Joe Biden's voters believe he won.
This seems to me a very perilous moment for democracy.
It's what I just described in cabinets on a national level,
you saw the same thing and you've come away with different
conclusions.
You think would be a responsible way for the media to talk about this then,
because one of the things I've been trying to do for the last couple of weeks
here is I'm saying, look, I don't know exactly what happened.
I don't think anyone really knows.
I do know that at about midnight Pacific time here that about eight
States that Trump had healthy leads in all stopped voting at the same exact
time. I'm not saying Trump won will, you know,
now it's going to go to the courts and there's all sorts of things happening,
but I've at least been trying to talk about it respectfully. Right?
So that it allows people to see, okay, let the process work.
And then at the end, if it comes out that yes, did I want Trump to win? Yes.
But if, if the courts look, look at everything and he doesn't win,
then so be it.
But I think what a lot of people are frustrated that that eight out of 10,
you just referenced.
I think what they're seeing is that the media won't even let you talk about it
and that if you talk about it,
you're going to be put on a list and you're going to be labeled a conspiracy
theorist, and you're going to get booted from social media and the rest of it.
And that strikes me as more of a problem.
Maybe then what actually happened at some point.
Well, no, I disagree with that. I mean,
I think the biggest problem is if the president doesn't leave
the white house and he's lost.
If we get there and he, and he has actually yes.
Of course. I mean, you know, look, I'm,
I'm sympathetic to much of your argument and your, your point of view on this.
But I mean that, and I, by the way,
I'm particularly irate about the fact that there are so many Democrats who
spent four years claiming that the American voting system had been fundamentally
undermined.
And indeed the Russians had stolen the 2016 election something for which they
never showed us any evidence, but they asserted. Anyway.
He literally said that, that it was an illegitimate election. I mean, it's yeah.
I'm, I'm I'm I read about that. I was, I raved about him for four years.
I'm I read about the fact that the same people now pretend that there is no such
thing as voter fraud in America. However,
the owners at this stage is on Donald Trump and his legal team to
prove that he won the election. Now I have to say,
I've paid fairly close attention to this. As I say, I mean, I, first of all,
I said the thing of going to bed and the result being different when you wake up
is, is not unheard of in elections. I mean, in the Brexit vote,
lots of people went to bed thinking that, um, uh,
that Britain was going to remain in the European union.
I remember it very clearly.
And of course then suddenly the results from Sunderland and elsewhere in the
North of England came through and wash.
We were out and the same people woke up the next morning, amazed,
but that's what happens sometimes and our actions. Um,
I do think that Donald Trump, uh, is behaving reprehensible at the moment.
I think that frankly,
I am very open for any and all explanations of voter fraud as
it is going on in America, as it has gone on.
I think whoever is president on January the 20th,
rather than as a point of absolute urgency should put together
a bipartisan nonpartisan cross-party is anting to look into
voter fraud, specifically mail-in voter fraud in the United States of America.
You cannot have another election after this one,
which would be a third in a row where people didn't believe the results if they
lost. So it seems to me to be real point of urgency, this,
but on election night,
when Donald Trump came out in the early hours of the morning and said, um,
I believe we've already won. We've won. As far as I'm concerned. He said,
I gas, I gas. I thought, Oh, how,
and there's several things about that. One is you better.
If you're the Trump team, you better provide really good fast about that.
And frankly,
what they've provided is not good enough proof yet they have
been providing, uh,
some things that sound to me like they are conspiracy theories,
unless they've got a lot of stuff to come. I hope for their sake,
they've got a lot of stuff to come,
or there are a lot of reputations that are being trashed all the time.
Well, that's what I said from [inaudible] it's like Sidney Powell,
she's either self emulating in front of us,
or she's about to break the greatest story in the history of modern times.
It's it's one or the other, right?
Yeah. The suspect it's the first. Uh,
and I think the same with Rudy Giuliani, you, you,
you can't give press conferences talking about dead Venezuelan leaders
and think that the citizenry should, I mean,
it's not just that you shouldn't treat the citizenry stupidly,
you should not mislead people's belief in the most
fundamental thing in our nations,
which is that we vote and some people win and some people lose them, you know,
who's lost and who's won. This is a really dangerous thing.
This is a dangerous element to be playing with. And,
and I worry deeply about the consequences of this.
But another thing to point out about this is that,
you know, I mean, you, everyone has to lose.
Sometimes I remember Michael Barone saying this to some conservative gathering
as once that many years ago. I think like Brian said, you know,
you have to lose some times, you know,
the evidence so far seems to be that the Republican nominee for the presidency
lost this time. Now here's, here's the kicker,
if I may say so for four years,
the question one of the questions has been,
why has Donald Trump not been able to recruit? Now,
there have been some very remarkable people who have worked for him and I
wouldn't do down any of them. I'm thinking of people like,
I think secretary of state, Mike Pompeo, um, uh, uh,
Elliot Abrams and others are some very,
very serious particular foreign policy figures who have worked for me.
I deeply admire, but there has been a question throughout the Trump presidency.
Why can he not, uh,
appear to get more people working with him?
Uh, more experienced people working for him, older hands, more trusted figures,
some non-family would be nice, uh, and so on and so forth.
What is the explanation? And I, you know,
it's one of those political questions that ends up answering itself.
It's because everyone worried, but at the end of the run,
he would pull some crap like this. That was why,
that was why I spoke to a lot of people in recent years in America and
said to them, you know, in American friends and said, you know,
would you consider taking this post? Why don't you consider taking that role?
And I always noticed that some of them, you know, early on and I would say,
you know, he's got four years in office. It's not nothing to be,
whatever position was being discussed. And I noticed always this reticence,
I think Neil Ferguson on your show said that there was always this risk that
Trump was going to do something or come down in a way that was a scandal of
Nixon of not only Nixonian proportions, but that would make Nixon look like,
you know, sort of a tea party, tea party means something else. Yeah.
Not a British team. Well, yeah. Yeah. [inaudible] okay. Cool.
I think, uh, and, and I think that's, um,
I think that what we're seeing at the moment may be the answer to
that question. I have seen it once else in politics,
in European continental politics with a much more minor political figure who the
same question was, why can't people around, why don't people trust them?
And in the end, the answer answered itself because he was going to in the end,
Paul crazy crappy poles. And, and I just,
I think less and less, the Trump team can very,
very swiftly provide evidence that is very good and persuasive.
They are playing with an element that they should not be playing with.
And I think it will,
it will deeply diminish the Republican party. If it allows it to go on,
it will diminish conservatives.
It will diminish the millions of millions of decent American voters who were
trying to send a very distinct message in 2016,
who were reviled for four years, insulted for four years,
called every imaginable name in for four years,
it will further demoralize them. And we can them.
I hope I hope if he has something, it comes out. Yeah.
By the way, Douglas, you know,
while I'm obviously sympathetic to the campaign and I wanted him to win,
I'm completely with you on that. It's like, if,
if there isn't anything there and they,
and they've truly done something here that was to destroy the system or
completely erode trust or anything else. Yeah.
Then it's almost the most dangerous thing. Well, I guess it would be the second,
most dangerous thing, you know, compared to actually rigging the election. So,
you know, w w we'll find out over the next couple of weeks.
If they have, if they, if you have Democrats did actually bring the election,
then it is indeed it is the most appalling crime against American democracy.
And there should be, uh, such a thorough investigation.
And so many people go into prison.
It would be the scandal of our lifetimes,
but if it isn't the case, if it isn't the case,
then it is also a great scandal because you cannot lie to the citizen about
this. I mean, I'm very, I'm very open to the argument of, you know,
four years ago, Hillary Clinton didn't really admit that she lost the election.
I spent years pretending she had only lost election because of the Russians and
something to do with a box on Facebook. A lot.
I thought that was contemptible. I think Hillary Clinton was again,
playing with fire to do her, the one piece of credit that one can do.
At least she didn't actually tunnel into the oval office and barricade herself
in it after the election in 2016.
It's the one thing Hillary Clinton has going for.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlist, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.